يوم اخر من ايام الغضب الفرنسي
هذه بعض مظاهره
يسابق الناس الزمن للحاق بالقطار
بعضهم فتح في وجهه امل الوصول الى عمله
البعض الاخر لم يجد ودا من توفيق اللحظه
لاقناع مشغله بسبب غيابه عن العمل اضراب
نقل حال بين ملايين الناس وبين وصولهم الى
عملهم خاصه
سباق معقد جدا لا توجد وسيله نقل ووقت
انتظار القطارات المتوفره طويل جدا وصلت
الى هنا لاجد الخط مغلقا لذلك الامر خطير
حقا اشعر بخيبه امل
هؤلاء هم كان يفترضوا ان يؤمنوا حركه
القطارات توقفوا عن العمل ليس رغبه في
اغابه الناس ولكن للضغط على الحكومه من
اجل تحسين شروط عمله
[موسيقى]
من غيره
نعمل في العطل وفي نهايه الاسبوع والمهنه
لم تعود لها اي جاذبيه في المقابل ليس
لدينا ما يعوض هذا
لكن الامر لم يتوقف عندماحطات القطار ولا
عند العاملين في قطاع النقل
فالمحتاجون كوثر ومن القطاعات كلها فكان
يوم الاضراب موعدها ومن جديد السعاده
الشارع هديره القديم
من الطلاب الى الطباخين وبينهم لائحه
طويله من الغاضب
[موسيقى]
اضرابات في شهر واحد والاحتقان ويزيد ولا
ينقص يقدم ذلك فكره عما ينتظر فرنسا هذا
شتاء فكل اسباب التوتر الاجتماعي تجمعت
غلاء وتضخم وفوقه هذا وذاك نقابات قويه
غاضبه من رئيس طالما سهمته لانه رئيس
مكرونه الذي جرب من قبل غضب الشارع لم
يبدي اي استعداد للاستجابه لمطلب زياده
الرواتب بل ان العكس تماما هو الذي يحصل
اكثر من ذلك اعلن انه ماضي في اصلاح قانون
التقاعد الذي سيرفع السنه مغادره العمل
الى الخامسه والستين رغم غياب اغلبيه
برلمانيه داعمه
دفع ذلك النقابات الى التحذير من ان
الاختناق الاجتماعيه قد يبلغ ذروته وحينها
قبل تعرف وعواقبها محمد البقالي الجزيره
باريس
[موسيقى]